ärzten oxana und ihre kollegen arbeiten
mitten im zerbombten raki
immer noch bis zur erschöpfung und
darüber hinaus
es ist nicht leicht für die menschen zu
uns zu kommen aber wir machen unseren
job weiter
seit einigen tagen operieren sie wieder
eigentlich zu gefährlich unter
kriegsbedingungen aber nicht zu
operieren sei für einige patienten ein
sicheres todesurteil
es kommen wieder mehr menschen ins
krankenhaus
sie halten es in den schutzbunker nicht
mehr aus vor allem die kinder auch für
sie ist oksana im dauereinsatz
viele menschen inaktiv sind auf
hilfsgüter angewiesen auch darum kümmert
sich die 44 jährige sammelt und verteilt
lebensmittel fleisch gibt es nur noch
selten wenn oxana etwas besorgen kann
helfen alle mit auch die ärzte doch es
fehlt nicht nur an essen und
küchenpersonal
medikamente besonders zur chemotherapie
werden immer knapper auch
krankenschwestern und pfleger fehlen und
eine neue wohnung denn ihre wurde
zerbombt ob sie das traurig oder wütend
macht
nein es dem passiert und jetzt warten
wir was als nächstes passieren wird
wir glauben dass gott unsere gebäude
unsere wohnungen wieder aufbauen wird
und dass wir unser leben wieder haben
werden
zum schluss erzählt oxana dass sie eine
21 jährige tochter hat kati die expertin
sie sagt gleich am anfang des krieges
nach warschau geflogen damit sie ihr
junges leben weiterleben kann
auch christina ist 21 jahre und aus
archiv auch sie will ihr leben
weiterleben doch ihre angst lässt sie
nicht los sie ist traumatisiert seit
drei wochen ständig auf der flucht eine
getriebene des krieges anfang märz
flüchtete christina mit ihrem freund
nach lemberg ihre familie wollte nicht
mit für sie unerträglich
ich hasse mich weil sie in kharkiv sind
und ich hier in sicherheit bin
nach zwei wochen kommt ihre familie nach
große erleichterung doch christina fühlt
sich nicht sicher in lemberg die
angriffe kommen erinnerungen an jacques
yves rauben ihr immer wieder zuversicht
und hoffnung da habe ich habe keinen
sinn mehr im leben gesehen ich weiß
nicht warum ich überhaupt noch irgendwo
hingehen arbeiten soll für was ich fühle
mich so zerstört in gelb bedeutet nichts
seine wohnung bedeutet nichts deine
kleidung bedeutet nichts
sie entscheidet sich nach polen zu
fliehen ihre mutter und großmutter
bleiben zurück in lemberg und auch ihr
freund denn er darf nicht ausreisen so
wie alle männer in der ukraine zwischen
18 und 60 jahren nach zwei tagen in
warschau über kommt christina die angst
der krieg könnte auch auf polen
überschwappen sie flieht nach berlin
kurz spürt sie ein hauch von
leichtigkeit
doch das erlebte holt sie immer wieder
ein sie will sie kann nicht bleiben muss
noch weiter weg bucht sogar einen flug
nach asien in der hoffnung sich endlich
irgendwo sicher zu fühlen
ich gehe in ein land verlassen ist dann
in das nächste und verlassen wie das
weil es einfach nicht sicher ist
nirgendwo auf der welt ich fühle
bis sich die lage in der ukraine
beruhigt hat wird sie weiter fliehen vor
dem krieg und ihrer eigenen angst
sicherheit das will auch katharina aus
ressort ihr ziel der eine mag dort und
ihr freund anders seit zwei jahren
führen sie eine glückliche fernbeziehung
doch dann kam der krieg und damit die
angst sich vielleicht nie wieder sehen
zu können
ich schreibe meinem freund die ganze
zeit dass ich in die gus weil ich nicht
weiß welche nachricht welche nachricht
die letzte sein coach
die situation in hessen spitzt sich zu
wer sich gegen die russischen besatzer
stellt lebt sehr gefährlich mitte märz
schreibt katharina
menschen verschwinden auf einmal in
meiner stadt das russische militär hält
nach aktivisten ausschau nach leuten von
der polizei vom sicherheitsdienst und
nach ehemaligen soldaten die kommen zu
ihnen nach hause und legen ihnen unter
die türen das ist total beängstigend
kurze zeit später erreichte uns
überraschend diese nachricht ich bin
jetzt im zug verlässt die ukraine ja ich
bin auf dem weg nach polen
ich weiß nicht genau wann ich sie sehen
werden aber es wird wohl bald sein auf
jeden fall noch heute ich bin
unglaublich aufgeregt ihr freund anders
hat sich sofort auf den weg nach krakau
gemacht und tatsächlich endlich können
sie sich wieder in die arme schließen
gemeinsam fliegen sie nach dänemark was
nach romantischem happy end klingt ist
für katharina nur schwer zu begreifen
mein kopf war mehr beschäftigt als
glücklich erst jetzt fange ich an zu
verstehen was passiert ist es jetzt kann
ich anfangen glücklich zu sein und
anders gegenwart zu genießen zu spüren
dass er wirklich dass
in hessen hat katharina wochenlang nicht
das haus verlassen nun realisiert sie
langsam dass sie in sicherheit ist und
sich frei bewegen kann
stell dir vor ich kann rausgehen und
bananen kaufen ich muss nicht im haus
bleiben und von ihnen träumen oder vier
stück wochen lang aufbewahren ich kann
rausgehen und bananen kaufen das ist
nicht selbstverständlich verstehst du
jeden tag gewöhnt sich katharina ein
bisschen mehr an dieses neue leben
leider ohne ihre eltern zwei wochen habe
katharina versucht sie zu überzeugen mit
zu gehen doch ohne erfolg sie bleiben zu
hause im krieg
christinas flucht geht weiter sie
befürchtet dass sie ihren freund so
schnell nicht wieder sehen wird doch die
hoffnung bleibt
wenn wir hin wollen wir natürlich zurück
nach prag und das wieder aufbauen dass
es zu 100 prozent sollen einer million
prozent sicher
zusammen und in sicherheit seien
katharina will jetzt dennis lernen
wieder als ingenieuren arbeiten einfache
wünsche für ein neues leben
wir sind nicht romantisch
offensichtlich nicht aber es ist
wirklich so gut dich zu sehen und dich
bei mir zu haben